a certain type of a person who likes a
nacho in the middle I don't know who it
is but it's not me what's up everybody
I'm in tasties kitchen making plantain
nachos with beer braised chicken it's
gonna be so good the tips are breaking
down chicken is all about finding the
creases so I always start with the leg
and the thigh and I pop back that muscle
and then from there I kind of work
around the oyster that's the best part
of the chicken I break down the wing
tips and you take off the chicken breast
you want to find that line that goes
straight down the middle and run your
knife right down the middle and then
just follow the bone all the way down
and take off all the meat I think using
the whole chicken for the dress is
really amazing because you're gonna get
literally every piece of the chicken and
each bite of the nacho so you're gonna
get chicken thighs mixed mixed with
chicken breast we're gonna get some wing
meat in there so when your friends are
saying oh I only one chicken brush or
like don't worry I have chicken breast
in here or I want chicken thighs don't
worry I have chicken thighs in here they
give you that overall flavor the really
great part of this is gonna be the
chicken skin I grew up eating plantain
chips with cheese on top they're like
nice grated cheese baked together with
like a really cool dipping sauce in my
house you always will see plantain chips
stacked to the ceiling I'm not like a
big like tortilla guy so when I'm
thinking of nachos I'm thinking plantain
chips and this is the showstopper like
you show up to your friend party with
plantain nachos they've never seen it
before and truly everybody's gonna run
to the table and they're gonna want
every piece of plantain every piece of
cheese and chicken together
so the beer-braised technique is the
beer is injecting all that really good
flavor into the chicken and braising it
is because I want the chicken to be
super moist on top of the nachos that's
why I'm using the brazing technique
avocado yogurt gives it a nice creamy
balance but it has a flavor that you
would get in guacamole so on lemon juice
or lime juice little bit spice this is
sour cream on steroids I'm giving you
everything you wanted nachos slightly in
a different way we're gonna reduce this
down into a pan sauce and we're gonna
fold this back in to the chicken so we
get all the flavor I want the notch on
the outside cuz I want to get all that
cheese I want that like nice big chunk
and nacho in the middle there's a
certain type of person I like to nacho
in the movie I don't know who it is but
it's not me I'm black beans all day the
great protein bin my nachos you have to
have black beans so now I'm gonna add a
little chicken so the cheese a little
cheddar pepper jack mozzarella this is
my favorite three cheese's I think it's
the best three cheese blend and give you
everything that you need I want that
extra like zestiness
in my nachos and that's what the pickle
jalapenos give you pepper jack is the
best hidden gem but it also just the
cheese melts amazing it gives you like
that nice extra flavor in the nachos you
can't make nachos without pepper jack
[Music]
oh yes